New York Times has this
headline the headline is this is not the
way to help depress
teenagers and it's a whole it's a it is
a uh an oped that is worth reading the
entire thing read a little bit of it
says Dr Saxby is a clinical psychologist
and professor of psychology at the
University of Southern California um
ever since the pandemic when rates of
teenage suicide anxiety and depression
spiked policy makers around the world
have pushed to make uh Mental Health
Resources more broadly available to
young people through program programming
in schools and on social media
platforms um the strategy is well
intentioned traditional therapy can be
expensive and timeconsuming access can
be limited by contrast larg scale light
touch interventions Tick Tock offerings
from Harvard's School of Public Health
grief coping workshops and junior high
aim to reach young people where they are
at relatively low cost but there's now
reason to think that this approach is
risky recent Studies have found that
several of these programs not only
failed to help young people they also
made their mental health problem s worse
understanding why these efforts
backfired Can Shed light on how Society
can and can't help teenagers who are
suffering from depression and
anxiety consider a social emotional
skills training school program called
wise teens led by clinical psychologist
and training it consists of eight weekly
hour-long classroom sessions in which
students learn to manage their emotions
with the help of tools and principles
drawn from cognitive behavior therapy
and Zen Buddhism last month the journal
Behavior research and therapy published
a study of about a thousand Australian
teenagers who were observed from 2017 to
2018 one group participated in Wise
teens another group participated in
standard health class curriculum and
just to summarize it turns out that the
students who were in this kind of um
therapeutic environment uh fared worse
and then there are other examples that
they bring forth of students who are in
these kind of therapeutic uh uh
programs meant to help them cope with
anxiety and depression but it actually
makes them
worse um
and uh why is that happening there's a
few theories that are put forward says
first by focusing teenagers attention on
mental health issues these interventions
may have unwittingly exacerbated their
problems Lucy folks and Oxford
psychologist calls the phen this
phenomenon prevalence inflation when
greater awareness of mental illness
leads people to talk of normal life
struggles in terms of symptoms and
diagnosis these sorts of labels begin to
dictate how people View themselves in
ways that can become self- fulfillment
fulfilling teenagers who are still
developing their identities are
especially prone to take psychological
labels to Heart instead of saying uh I
am nervous about x a teenager might say
I can't do X because I have anxiety a
reframing that research shows undermines
resilience by encouraging people to view
everyday challenges as insurmountable
anyway okay so you could read the entire
thing this is um what we're starting to
see is that more and more people are
beginning only beginning just barely
starting to understand the problems with
living in a therapeutic culture a
culture where everyone is encouraged to
constantly think about themselves and
their own emotional states and be going
to therapy and be taking medicine and
everything all the time a society where
the human condition has been categorized
and medicalized and
diagnosed um I think people are starting
to see the issues with it now I've been
talking about this problem for years
mostly I've been ignored I'm still
mostly ignored about it but I think in
the coming years people will
increasingly wake up to this and they
will see that we have just entirely
handed our culture our country
ourselves our
Humanity over to the psychiatric
industry which means that over time
people will see that the issues stretch
far beyond what the New York Times has
been talking about um what we've done
you know focusing just on young people
for a moment what we've we've done is we
we we have programmed them to look
inwards
always so like they don't see the
outside world they're constantly staring
back at themselves thinking about
themselves thinking about how they're
feeling think about how they feel about
how they feel and how they feel about
how they feel about how it creates this
like infinite
regress of
self-obsession and they can't get out of
their own heads and when I say can't get
out of their their own heads not in the
sense that we used to use phrase is like
that you know in the past if you had
said that oh that person can't get out
of their own head uh you might have
meant it in the sense that like their
head's in the clouds and this is someone
who's say very philosophically minded uh
very intellectual person someone uh that
can't get out of his own head because
he's constantly contemplating the
mysteries of the universe or he's
thinking about the nature of
Consciousness and where it comes from
and that sort of thing
um there there's that
sense in which a person can't get out of
their own heads and the thing is you
know say what you want about that kind
of mentality it's obviously much better
for the individual and for
Humanity than this sense of not being
able to get out of your own head which
is that we've got all these young people
and older people who are trapped in
their own heads because not because
they're thinking about something Beyond
themselves and they're contemplating
Mysteries of the universe and not
because they're they're they're too
intellectual and not practical enough
but because they're complet they're just
bundles of emotion and they're they're
always thinking about all of their
atttention is is turned back within
themselves the holidays are rapidly
approaching but we can find peace and
calm in the craziness of the season with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app in the world immerse yourself in
Christmas and Advent prayers meditations
and peaceful Christmas music hallow also
offers an extensive library of Bible
reading plans accompanied by insightful
Reflections and Audi guided medit ations
whether you're a seasoned Bible reader
or just starting your journey Hall
provides a platform for you to engage
with scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the hall app
the hall app also helps you uh connect
with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the SE with prayer
meditation and Christmas music on hallow
download the app for free at hall.com
Walsh for 3 months free that's hall.com
Walsh I've got a holiday gift idea for
you that's sure to make you a hero of
the season now we all know the holidays
can be a bit hectic the shopping the
cooking the never-ending list of things
to do but fear not because I've
discovered a gift that's not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
it is the gift of genell skincare from
now until Christmas genell's most
popular package has a special discount
just for my listeners at gel.com Walsh
treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skin care in the world
these those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness and yes even a
sagging jawline will disappear right
before your eyes with genus cell's most
popular package collection Jus cell
promises immediate effects you'll see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
or your money back Jus cell made
Christmas come early this year they sent
down a ton of their products for our
crew to try the crew was so excited to
get their hands on the products and see
for themselves how great they truly are
everyone was extremely impressed with
the quality and how different it felt in
comparison to other skincare products
you deserve to look and feel your best
this holiday season go to jal.com Walsh
to get this incredible holiday discount
every order today is instantly upgraded
to free express shipping that's jus.com
walshay this is what the therapeutic or
what I would call our therapeutic
culture encourages it's how people are
uh are conditioned and we just can't
function this
way and then part of that
is and you see this especially in young
people it's part of what this article is
is is grasping at is that you've got
young people that that don't
understand that suffering and
discomfort
anxiety um sadness these are all normal
this is all part of being human and you
will
never Escape
them um you just
won't and and you might say well that's
not fair so you're telling me that that
that I will always have suffering and
that there will always be pain and
sadness in my life no matter what I do
yeah that is just that's human existence
that's what human existence
entails um anxiety especially it's why
I'm always talking about the fact that
we've turned anxiety into a disease is
so insane I
I and I know that most people still are
not far enough along here to this is
this is I'm going too far for most
people when I even if people that track
me up till now when I say that when I
suggest that that anxiety is not at all
a mental illness that's why well no no
no that's not true I I I have anxiety
it's different for me you don't
understand I need medicine my anxiety is
different from yours it's so much worse
how do you know
that how the hell do you know that
you're not in anybody else's mind do you
understand you're not in anyone else's
mind that you're experiencing these
emotions and you're simply assuming that
it is so much worse for you than anybody
else do you understand that that
assumption is based in nothing at
all no anxiety is part of life like
everyone experiences anxiety at some
level like always I there's always at
least a a a uh Baseline level of anxiety
that undergirds all of of human
experience that doesn't sound very fun
yeah you're it's not I it's not I'm not
saying it's good it just is
though and we have now created
generations of people who do not
understand this like they don't
understand what it is to be
human that that's what's at stake here
what's at stake is a is a society of
people who don't know what it they don't
know how to be people they don't know
what it means to be a
person
um and
uh I'm glad that some people are
starting to catch on very slowly to this
issue uh but we need to speed it up we
need to speed the realization process up
because pretty soon we are going to live
in a country where literally everybody
is on a psychiatric drug and has been
numbed into basically unconsciousness
that that is where we're headed if we
don't uh if this process of of realizing
that I'm right U does not speed up quite
a bit if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed